not care about people's opinion but how
do you practically do it well let's play
who do you think will most carry weight
for you whose opinion you're most
worried about like cool people on Tick
Tock which you could be I understand
that it doesn't sound like it's gonna be
your mother she loves you and has the
framework in a good way too much so who
I think it would be like friends even
old friends even people I don't even
talk to anymore what's he doing who does
he think he is exactly it makes sense I
don't know how to say this in any other
way it'd be a really bad idea to not
follow your dreams because of Tyrone
from fourth grade even more
interestingly I want you to go through
that adversity is the foundation of
success if you feel like you're not
ready for that that's the thing you
should most be doing anybody who's
listening if you feel like you're not
ready for friends to judge you you
should be putting yourself in a position
that friends judge you more not less